so I had the longest cat call my life
recently
this guy yelled out he goes it beautiful
and I ignored him and then he goes
friend and I still ignored him and then
he got fed up and goes [ __ ] and I was
like we just had an entire relationship
like that was all of the stages so kind
of missed him now I am speaking of
relationships I just got married so
that's pretty exciting it's my second
time so if you want to retract your
applause I totally understand I've been
there before but I my husband and I
we're not sure if we want kids so right
now we're just doing pullout cuz
whatever you know I like a surprise and
we were very excited about pullout too
excited I uh and you know whenever he
goes to celebrate on my body we clean it
up with baby wipes right because that's
what they're for it's in the name wiping
potential babies off of you
I'm just like
goodbye Giovanni you know so long Stella
just metallian if you couldn't tell by
the names parents very proud of the
names not of that joke at all I am part
of why I want a kid is because I want
another excuse to not have to go out at
night I really hate going out at night
when I was young I loved it I was like
in my 20s like let's get this party
started and in the second I hit 35 it
turned into let's hope it spot is
canceled Oh cancel text it is the best
when you get a cancel text you know I
just want to like take off my day
sweatpants slip into my night sweatpants
hop on the couch smoke a joint watch
Netflix menu I never pick a show just on
season eight of scrolling and I just
don't really see the point in going out
anymore like all of our interactions
when you go out everyone's just on their
phones right there it's buried on their
phones and I feel like the way we use
social media is sort of the new
bar-hopping you just go from app to app
looking for a connection or validation
you hop on over to Facebook and that's
like a townie bar right where everyone
from high school still hangs out and
then sometimes your aunt is there
dancing for some reason so then you hop
on over to Twitter and Twitter's this
like rowdy pug where if you say anything
wrong someone will kill you right that's
what Twitter is so then you hop on over
to Instagram and Instagram is a strip
club where the strippers tell you
inspirational quotes for some reason
that's why it's like you're in a thong I
didn't need a Maya Angelou poem you know
I see what you're doing here I will see
the time that I hated social media the
most was when I was single because I
hated that I would like hook up with
people and then I have to see them
forever online and I just I hate it
right like I get very attached to people
when I sleep with them and the best way
I can describe it is you know my body is
my home right and so if I've cleaned up
and invited somebody in I want them to
stay for a while
right or at least come back to visit I
think I'm a good host
you know I am I've great snacks
however some people they only want to
hang out in the basement and I get it
because basement historically funnest
part of a house right that is where you
have slumber parties and maybe there's a
foosball table down there it's like fun
time and the basement it's sometimes
people don't want to travel up to your
attic cuz this is where the crazy clown
doll lives right and they're like ah you
know it's just cluttered with all these
boxes that say dad you know like I don't
wanna I don't want to go through that
okay thank you so much
[Applause]